this is the anonymous British
nineteen-year-old who said she's been
gang-raped in Cyprus by 12 Israelis only
to end up convicted herself now her
mother has told a British broadcaster
that the party resort of Ayia Napa is
dangerous the place isn't safe she said
it's absolutely not safe and if you go
and report something that's happened to
you you're either laughed at as far as I
can tell or in the worst case something
like what's happened to my daughter it
may happen she's back to campaign
trending on Twitter to boycott Cyprus
the teenager was convicted on Monday of
lying about the rape angering women's
rights campaigners who say the victim
has been turned into the criminal she
says pressure from Cypriot police back
in July made her retract her accusation
against the 12 Israelis when they
arrived home at Ben Gurion Airport some
of the young men celebrated with
champagne and insulting chance against a
woman after her conviction
her lawyer vow to appeal against the
decision the decision of the court is
respected however we respectfully
disagree with it we believe that there
have been many violations in the
procedure and the rights of fair trial
of a client have been violated
we are planning to appeal the decision
to the Supreme Court hoping that our
client will find justice in Cyprus some
of the woman's supporters suspect
cypresses economic ties with Israel may
have influenced the case and they say
cypresses legal system is corrupt an EU
report in 2018 said the country hasn't
fully implemented 14 of its 16 reform
recommendations the UK Foreign Office is
raising concerns with Cyprus about
what's happened to the woman but the
government's in Nicosia insists its
courts are independent the British woman
will be sentenced on Tuesday
Rory talyn's al Jazeera well the woman's
lawyer Nicoletta Harlan Badu who we've
just been seeing in Rory's report there
joins us live now from Nicosia can you
start by telling us about your clients
condition where is she right now and how
is she doing
yes thank you the client obviously is
not in a very good situation
psychologically she suffers from PTSD
something that was put in front of the
court as well but the experts opinion
was not accepted by the court
she obviously it has been a very
difficult period for her
the last five to six months because she
had to stay on bail conditions in Cyprus
her whole life has been has been on a
freeze for this five months how to stay
in this country pending the trial so
obviously she's not in a very good
condition we try to prepare her of
course for the outcome of the case
because we to be honest we expected this
outcome as you were saying you were
saying that it's she is obviously in a
very difficult situation right now she's
already been kept there for five to six
months you are planning to appeal this
decision so the next step is that it
goes to the Supreme Court but what can
be done to expedite this because it
doesn't seem like it's going to be
resolved anytime soon
yes this is true but it doesn't
necessarily mean that she has to stay in
Cyprus on appeal it will only do not
depend on the sentencing that will take
place on the 7th of January and the
decision of the court as to what
sentence is going to impose in case that
Court decides to impose further
imprisonment because she already spent
one month in prison in pretrial
detention then we can also request an
expedition of the appeal procedure in
case she's back in prison can you
prescribe these circumstances or the
sequence of events around which she
changed her story because of course
police in Cyprus they've denied any
wrongdoing and they say that the
decision to retract the allegation was
her own well the sequence of events
basically she was called again for
clarifications according to the police
for a third time after ten days of
reporting the rape she was kept in the
police station for a period of almost
eight hours the point which she was she
stopped being considered as a victim of
a crime and started being considered as
a suspect for another crime is not very
clear because she was initially called
in for further for a further statement
as a victim of a crime she did not have
an access to lawyer either as a victim
because she has the right to have a
lawyer as a victim as well or as a
suspect and she claims and this is what
we support that her statement was given
under duress and this is of course there
is an intermediary decision of the court
in and so just to be clear about this
when she signed the statement retracting
the rape claimed she had no access to
legal advice no access to translators
and there is absolutely no record of the
conversations that she had with police
officers is that I mean is that a
standard procedure over there it
shouldn't be a standard procedure
because according to the laws and
according to she has to have write
access to a lawyer normally during the
investigation they have to record down
the statements given as a suspect even
in this case there is not any statement
given as a suspect of a crime it is not
clear at which point she was cautioned
about being a suspect and therefore this
is not standard procedure F nothing no
all right thank you very much Nicoletta
all along we do thank you for taking the
time to speak with us the defense lawyer
is there for the 19 year-old teenager
there in Nicosia